today we're talking all about
connections that were made during our
first
season one of my favorite things to do
is connect celebrities with everyday
people
as well as with each other it's always
fun to see how people relate to one
another
um like when nicole byer reacted to
jason derulo check this out
okay here's the thing instead i'm gonna
talk about it like teach me one thing
what's one thing you do
so i'm gonna catch um you have to have
to learn them
all right so show us okay so
ah so um so cats walk
in in a different way right they walk
same arm same leg so it's a little
different than us so
i mean it's all those little odds all
those i just pictured myself
yeah so it's it's like that because we
go from
two feet to four feet because we're not
we're not like just regular cats we're
like cat people
so we go in you know from from be
standing in a you know two feet into
going into all fours
so you so you'll be in a in a
conversation with somebody high
athletics
yeah yes a lot of core so you'll be on
two feet and then you'll just be having
a conversation
that's why they didn't call me oh shoot
i'm in
i tried it it works wonders it works
exactly i'm like you come with a girl
like that she's like yes
i don't even know what i'm talking about
no no if the dude just dropped to all
fours and started pairing at me i'd be
like what is happening
i would definitely start taking my
clothes off i would rather a man bark at
me i'd be like oh okay
okay so you could see my face in that
clip clip too like
like what like jason dorillo is back
right now
get him in here where are you jason
where's hannah kelly
hi man i'm in a spacesuit so i'm having
an awesome day
yes we are we're it's like celebrating
the launch
of our get it launched yeah we're clever
jason over here i love that kelly
clarkson show
um so i have a question because my
friends and family went nuts for your
cat thing
so i mean how did your fans react to the
cat demonstration you did on our show
oh man it was literally hilarious i love
i i actually
really love the people that had no idea
what it was and that it wasn't
like like it was like i was just
reenacting a cat it was not for a movie
or anything at all
they were like they were like what in
the hell is he doing
i know that was so impressive regardless
of the it was so impressive and
controlled you're so muscular
um and that was i mean nicole byers
hilarious that whole thing was so funny
we're kind of celebrating um some of the
best ones that
takes on our show from season one and
everybody loved that one so
is it true that you do crazy things to
celebrate connecting
with more people on tick tock yeah so
every time uh we reach another
milestone another million i do these
things called
millie mills where i uh create like
these outlandish
uh desserts or like crazy meals that you
know we all kind of dream about
having but i've never actually tasted it
but it's been it's been like
it's been pretty crazy in terms of how
good they have been
you know a lot of people are like i
don't know if i would like that amount
of sugar
trust me it is unreal it is
it's so much i've ever actually said
that sentence in my entire existence
i think i'm i'm like elf like like if
there's sugar i'm
in um yeah
okay so you did this crazy thing um on
tick tock it's
it's a death jump on tick tock right is
that what's called
yeah so basically um so you drop a
tissue from the top of the stairs
and you have to like run and try to
catch it before it touches the floor
so um that sounds like a workout
yeah so i mean tick tock has all of
these kind of crazy challenges that you
can you know i'm saying do with the
people that you care about so you're not
just like
on netflix all day long playing video
games
it's just active things to do um
especially during these times right but
mine ended a little a little tricky you
know you know i i
i injured my knee a little bit it was a
little painful
i feel like all in you're one of those
people that plays sports is like all in
oh it's all or nothing i'm competitive
oh man me too
oh it gets me in so much trouble um well
i have been um writing a lot i've been
recording a lot and i know a lot of
artists have right now have you made any
new music during the pandemic
i have a ton a ton i mean it's been
incredible to just be
like i said uh it's in my own space you
know i have a
uh recording facility here and man it's
it's just been cool from a lot of
different perspectives too because i was
just
in a you know i was signed to warner
brothers for 12 years
you know and i'm i'm finally uh free of
that situation
you know it was a little it's a little
cantankerous because there was
four different regimes that came in
during my
my uh my time my life that that is my
life
yeah and you know when when there's so
many different regimes right you're just
so far removed from the people that you
began with
like it's hard to like get into a groove
into a balance
into uh even a creative space sometimes
because
you know you want to make sure that uh a
uh you're seeing eye uh
promotion wise you're seeing eye to eye
creatively you know so like it was it
was a real uh
it became a real issue but now i'm free
and i've actually just released a song
called um
uh take you dancing yeah i know i know
it's great that's awesome yeah thank you
so much yes i've been
i've released like uh four songs thus
far
in this in this pandemic